As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. I'm so happy to be able to
talk to you today. [music]
And mashallah, my brother, our Sheikh
Ali Hamuda, is doing a great job. Waqf
Forever is [music] a very, very uh
beautiful cause because the reward of
what you give is not just at the moment
of giving, but rather it is [music]
prolonged for a very, very long time and
it lasts for as long as that waqf
continues to generate to generate some
form of [music] benefit. So, I highly
recommend Waqf Forever. As an ambassador
of Abdullah Aid, I know the the uh
partnership that we have is amazing.
[music]
And uh not many people understand the
concept of waqf, yet the reward is far
greater through the waqf. So, inshallah,
if you can support Waqf Forever,
uh it will be really, really amazing and
very, very rewarding.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. This will be a video, not
a reaction video, not clickbait, not
whatever you want to call it, inshallah.
This will be different, a heart-to-heart
that I would like to have with you guys,
especially for those who are sinners
like myself. I mean, those who are
committing sins, uh those who are
committing zina, drinking alcohol, maybe
involved in robbery.
I mean, even as bad as someone maybe
taking the life of somebody else. Now,
you might be watching this and you might
be thinking you have no hope. Yes? And
I'll be honest with you, that was
something that I felt long, long time
ago. I would say 14 years ago. You know,
I've been a Muslim 13 years. And
subhanallah, um the lifestyle that I
come from, as I told you guys, uh
clubbing, partying, and all that kind of
stuff, alhamdulillah. Uh well,
astaghfirullah, not alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah that I came to Islam. But
astaghfirullah to that lifestyle. And
subhanallah, I want to speak to the
sinners, the the people out there who
subhanallah are indulged in this. They
don't know how to get out of it. In my
13 years of experience as a Muslim, I've
noticed alhamdulillah Allah
he he nurtures you. He teaches you. The
greatest of all teachers teaches you
um tawakkul, teaches you trust in him,
to know that the risk comes from him.
And these are things that a lot of born
Muslims they don't really understand.
They don't understand the power of risk.
They don't understand
how tawakkul has changed my life
forever. As a non-Muslim, you know where
my money came from. I thought I have to
earn from any means. Haram halal we
didn't know about halal. So subhanallah
even committing sins. I can remember
times where there was a specific sin
that I would really really struggle with
and I couldn't help myself. And
committing that sin, especially knowing
when I was at a stage when I knew Islam
is the truth. And subhanallah I can
remember my first Ramadan as well. And
repeating that cycle over and over again
because you couldn't help yourself.
Because you was indulged in sins that
you couldn't let go. And a lot of you
guys will relate to this because you
need to understand there's two parts to
yourself. Like Allah says in the Quran
in Surah Amma, he says that I've created
with inclination towards evil and good.
So you've been created with that for
Allah subhanallah to test you. You
really need to understand that. And that
evil thoughts that come to your mind
that I used to have some really deep
satanic evil thoughts that would come to
me. You need to really divide yourself
and say, "That's not me. That there is
not me." And subhanallah I would
struggle with this sin. And I can
remember times as a grown man, you know,
who's involved in athlete athletics or
whatever it is for that matter, I would
cry. I would cry every time I would go
and commit that sin, I would cry. Why?
Because I knew Islam was the truth. I
didn't take my shahada. And why? Because
I felt that and this a lot of reverts um
or those on the verge of accepting Islam
would think uh relate to this. You
think, "Until I stop sinning, then I
will go and do that." You know, and
that's the biggest plot of shaytan
because it works you're you're working
the other way around. Shaytan always
makes you want to do the opposite. Okay?
That's why you know they say Satan is
satanic. They do everything the wrong
way around, the opposite way.
So subhanallah you think to yourself,
and I would think to myself, once I've
stopped sinning, then I will accept
shaha- my take my shahada. Once I've
stopped sinning, I'll start praying
salah. Once I've stopped sinning, I'll
start reading the Quran. And when I
stopped sinning, I will do zakat. That
is the total opposite. It's rather when
you start praying salah, it's rather
when you give in sadaqa, it's rather
when you do these actions is what's
going to stop you from sinning, not vice
versa. That's the reason why you take
the akal, our logic over what Allah says
prescribe. Our logic is flawed cuz we're
limited. And that's why you should
always turn back to the Quran and
Sunnah. And brothers and sisters, when I
would commit these sins, and I would cry
and cry, and I would hate the sin. You
know why? Cuz I knew Allah existed. I
knew Islam was the truth. And I felt
ashamed, and this is how you would feel.
You feel ashamed that the one that's
created the heavens and the earth, and
you acknowledge him, and you love him.
And I know you guys love him. Because
don't let Shaitan make you feel that you
are odd, and you're a sinner, and Allah
hates you. No. Allah subhanallah loves
you. And Allah wants the best for you.
So, understand that, and don't ever put
yourself down and think I'm not good
enough. I'm not this Wellahi, this is
from Shaitan. Crying is a is the first,
the scholars say, is a step to
uh repentance. To hate the sin. Yes, to
hate the sin. It's a first step to
repentance. So, wallahi, I would do
that. And believe me, wallahi, Allah is
my witness.
All I would do is
reminds you of the eye in the Quran in
Surah Talaq, where Allah subhanallah
says, "If you fear me,
I will give you a way
from places you can never imagine."
Allah subhanallah, when we talk about
risk, we think it's only money. Allah
will provide for you when it comes to
leaving sins.
Allah will provide for you in different
ways. It's not just monetary.
So, wallahi, I can remember that I hated
the sin so much, and I would cry so
much, and wallahi, I repented one day,
and I said, "I've had enough." Like,
wallahi, I can remember driving past
Eastlands Masjid, and I parked on a
double yellow line. I did not care if my
car gets towed, bro. I had enough. I
went there, repented,
took my shahada, and someone taught me
how to pray salah. Alhamdulillah, and
he's getting all the rewards for that.
And I can remember my first Ramadan, and
there was one thing that I said to
myself is if there's anything I'm not
going to change doing this religion is
wake up for Fajr.
That's one thing I can't do. And for you
guys that are watching this just before
Ramadan, you might be thinking, "You
know what? I don't know if I'm going to
stop committing zina in Ramadan. I don't
know if I'm going to stop drinking in
Ramadan. I don't know if I'm going to
stop stop robbing people in Ramadan. I
don't know if I'm going to stop
disrespecting my mom and this that
whatever it is for that matter."
And believe me, I used to feel the same
way when it came to specifically many
other sins as well, but specifically
Fajr. I said, "I I can't do that." I
mean, I couldn't pray like I was praying
certain prayers cuz it was I was new to
it. But I can remember one thing,
subhanallah, being a Muslim for 13 years
now, there's one thing that I've
realized is that
and when people come to me, like for
example, I the the statement that I
cannot wake up for Fajr is true.
Now, you might guys be shocked. I was
like, "Yes, I I'm telling you
you can't stop committing zina in
Ramadan. You can't stop drinking alcohol
in Ramadan. Maybe you can't even stop if
you're gang women, you're killing
people. You I don't think you can stop
that in in in um Ramadan. Or
disrespecting your mom in Ramadan, or
doing all those sins. I'm telling you
straight to your face. Now, you might be
thinking, "Brother Ali, what on earth
are you talking about? I mean, is this a
video to help us to change or get worse
or lose hope?" You need to understand
the reality, which I have understood.
You yourself
cannot do it.
Accept that reality. You yourself cannot
do it. But this doesn't mean you don't
put the effort.
What I understood was this. The first
year of that Ramadan, I couldn't wake up
for Fajr,
but I would pray as soon as I woke up.
However, the second year of Ramadan, I
said, "No, I cannot. My Allah, I know
who he is, and he's giving me so much
blessings. I cannot
go another year
without praying like like I'm not waking
up for Fajr, struggling with it."
And wallahi, let me tell you something.
You know what Allah looks at? Allah
looks at
the sacrifice you're going to do.
Allah looks at how bad do you want to
leave that sin? Allah wants to see how
effort how much effort how much
sacrifice you're going to do.
>> [snorts]
>> And when we look at Ibrahim alaihis
salam, when he was asked to sacrifice
his son, we think the first sacrifice he
had to do is to talk to his son.
Rather, no. Some scholars say the first
thing he had to sacrifice
was to internally accept that I'm going
to sacrifice my son. Because if he
didn't sacrifice that internally, he
would not be able to do it physically.
So, it starts here. That's what Allah
says in the Quran, we do not change the
condition of man until he changes what's
within himself. You have to put the
effort to the best of ability. You might
be walking towards zina or robbery or
drinking alcohol or gambling.
But ultimately, let me tell you this,
you and I cannot stop those sins.
Can we put effort to try to? Yes.
And once you put the effort, like Allah
when he told Musa alaihis salam to hit
the water and the sea departed, when
Allah told Maryam alaihis salam to shake
the tree as a pregnant woman
to see the effort you're going to put
in.
And then Allah's aid and help came. Not
the other way around, not sitting at
home and not doing and actively just
sitting and not caring. No, no, no, no,
no. Hating the sin, crying about it,
actively trying to stop it, but
ultimately, you and I and the sins I was
committing and you're going to be
sinning cuz this is a video to sinners
like us. Till this day, I'm still a
sinner.
That Allah will help you do it. You
yourself cannot do it. But Allah can
make you do it. Because the statement is
true, I can't do it. But then say no one
can help me stop doing it doing it.
That's not true. Cuz that's where Allah
comes in. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
the missing key when you put the effort
in, when you hate that sin, when you
repent, when you fall into it over and
over again. But when Allah sees how bad
you want to stop it, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is my witness. I can remember
that sin that I used to commit and I'm
not talking about Fajr.
A major sin that I used to commit.
And wallahi I can remember, it's as if
someone put me to sleep in a coma and I
woke up a year and a half later and I
thought to myself,
Subhanallah, bro, I used to commit this
specific sin.
What happened? Bro, I I got into the
Dawah scene. And when I got into the
Dawah scene, I got so occupied with
Dawah and I loved it so much and I
brought so much happiness and
contentment to my heart.
I totally forgot about that thing, bro.
I don't know how. It's like it was the
reason I remember. You know Men in Black
when it goes flash and you forget
everything. It's as if I forgot and
remembered it about a year and a half
later and I thought, Yo, man, I used to
There was There was a sin that I used to
do.
It's as if Allah occupied me and that's
why when Allah says,
"If you fear me, genuinely fear and you
hate and cry that you hate the sin." Do
you really think Allah's going to let
you carry on that sin? He's not. Once
you show your loyalty in that manner,
and I realized, Subhanallah,
I would have never in a million years
think that the way I'm going to move
away from that sin is by Allah occupying
me with Dawah and I forget that.
And Subhanallah, not that the
temptations or this that or whatever I
was being tested with didn't come back,
but it made me forget that and I was now
seeking things in like Allah says, you
know, if you uh leave something for the
sake of Allah, Allah will replace it
with something better.
And this video is for you guys before
Ramadan to acknowledge that I am a
sinner till this day and I am working on
sins from 14, 15 years ago till this
day.
So, I want you to acknowledge and
understand that I'm a human like you.
You might watch my videos and think,
"Wow, this that etc." But you don't know
the struggles that I go through.
Alhamdulillah, we're not hypocrites that
we call to people something that we
don't do. What I'm saying is that the
struggle is still there. And I want you
to know to not lose hope this Ramadan
and have a fresh beginning.
Before Ramadan, when it's starting,
whatever it is, go and have a ghusl.
And say, "Oh Allah, I beg of you and
help you and cry to your Lord. I don't
care if you're a man or a woman. Cry to
your Lord and say oh Allah, let me have
a Ramadan. And I don't care if you may
fall into that sin again. Do not lose
hope. Repent, start again. Repent, start
again. And I want you to know that I was
in your shoes once upon a time and there
is nothing special about me.
Do you not think that I'm something
special or I do doubt I'm more holy than
you. I'm not. I still sin to this day.
And I want you to know that subhanallah
you can change as well. Don't let anyone
make you feel that you cannot wear that
hijab this Ramadan. Or brother that you
can't stop involved in haram income,
riba, drugs, whatever it is for that
matter, or insulting your parents. Yes?
Or for those who have wronged other
people. Be wrong in your family,
friends, whatever it is, your wife, your
husband. Today, this Ramadan can be a
change for you. I wanted to do this
video for you guys inshallah before
Ramadan to know that subhanallah wallahi
if you put the effort in, Allah will
change you because he's changed me for
the better and I am trying to still get
better at it. So may Allah subhana wa
ta'ala make this Ramadan a means for you
to get closer and you can do it and I
believe in you that you can do it. I was
where you was once upon a time and you
will be inshallah better than me not
that I'm anything special once upon a
time speaking and giving advice here to
others. So brothers and sisters
inshallah, repent and have a fresh start
this Ramadan and believe me this might
be the Ramadan that will change you
forever. And don't forget we are not
even promised Ramadan. Make dua that
Allah allow us to see Ramadan and to get
closer to him inshallah. And I wanted to
share this message with you guys and a
video a bit different and I'm going to
do more of these inshallah as much as I
can. May Allah subhana wa ta'ala protect
you guys and allow you to make the most
of best of Ramadan and get closer to him
inshallah. And do not forget the hadith
of the prophet salaam of the man who
killed 99 people and all he was looking
for is the mercy. And I'm telling you
with this video Allah's Rahman mercy is
there. Yes, so much so that man who was
killing those people when he was not
when he lost hope and he went to that
monk and the monk said, "You'll never be
forgiven." He killed him, too.
But when he came to a person and that
person gave him direction and said, "You
will be forgiven. Just go to this land."
So much so the scholars say on his way
to that land he dies. And the angel of
wrath and the angel of mercy come and
they are debating one another to say
we're going to take him.
And the the angel of mercy say, "No, he
was on his way to repentance." They
said, "But he didn't reach the land." So
much so that they argue and bicker and
they come to an agreement that if he was
closer to the land of mercy, repentance,
he would be taken by the angel of mercy.
If he was not by the angel of wrath. The
scholars are saying that Allah shifted
uh
earth for him. Because you know why? He
came with effort. He came with effort.
And guess what? When you come with
effort, what did Allah do? Allah said,
"Leave the rest to me." Allah shifted
the entire planet earth
that it is closer to the land of
repentance.
That's what Allah will do for you as
long as you are willing to go on that
path of mercy and repentance.
Till next time, assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh. Please share
this with your friends and family
from anyone. You don't know who's going
through what that this might be that
little push they need from a sinner like
myself to another sinner.
Till next time, assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.